why do you do this I got that question
from one of my readers I helped with a
question that they had about getting in
the media and the response was great you
are a godsend thank you but why do you
do this helping strangers you will
probably never meet and for me it's easy
because I love helping entrepreneurs I
believe that entrepreneurs have the
ability to make the world a better place
and I have the power to help them do
that and it makes me feel good helping
people out the best parts of my day
really are seen a comment to come back
from you guys on YouTube from the
feedback from the videos and when I meet
entrepreneurs face to face and they're
in this fog and they're not sure what to
do next and they're struggling they feel
like they tried everything and it's just
not working and nobody believes in them
and they're having so much problems
getting their business going and I know
I can help them and I give them some
advice and most of the time free advice
right like I'm not getting paid to do
this video right now but it makes me
feel good and so I do it and it gives me
more energy and it and it makes me happy
and if you're if you're looking at
starting the business the worst mistake
you can do is start a business just
trying to make money I make money
through my business but it's not my main
goal in the business I do it to do it
you should do your business to do it you
do it because you love it you do because
it's right you do it because it makes
you feel good you do it because it's
helping people and I guess we will live
in such a world where we're not enough
people are doing that that I would even
get a question like this why do you help
people who you've never met why do you
do this everybody should do this not
entrepreneurs what you should do you you
do what you're good at you should be
helping people who need what you're good
at and if you do that enough and you're
really good at it the money will come
so I'll keep doing it I'll keep helping
you guys out I love the questions when
they come in every time I see it quite
who come in I used to do these videos
are you sorry used to answer questions
on email somebody would writing with a
question I'd spend 20 minutes writing a
response then I thought you know what I
can help a lot more people if I turned
it into a video and that's how i started
the YouTube channel I wanted to be able
to reach more people and when I'm
answering questions it's not just
helping one person it's helping
thousands of people who have the same
problem so I do it to do it I do it
because I love it and you should do for
your business belief feels you watching
like the video thumbs up below if you
want me to keep doing more of this stuff
for you leave a comment underneath that
keeps me going every day and if you have
a question for your business that I can
help out with please leave it below I'd
be happy to give you a response thank
you so much and I'll see you soon